uh very well versed in the opening as
well um he's kind of the typical player
who's been brought up in the computer
generation he loves to calculate he
loves to be very direct if possible
and uh we've seen that in his games
that's why he's had a few defeats
everyone does but he's also had some
great victories because he's not scared
to go for the opponent and uh here we
see a queen's pawn opening
um up until this last move it was
following the game neiman carlson
like this one's still going now but uh
maybe carson will show us why he was so
scared of continuing that game
because this is uh
this is good for white this is a very
typical opening it's now what we call
the nimzo indian defense and this last
move is maybe the riskiest one of the
most provocative moves it's asking black
to capture the white knight with the
dark squad bishop there we go there's
been an exchange but white gets these
doubled pawns now on the c file and long
term that's that's pretty much an
eternal weakness
in return white gets the bishop pair two
bishops now black in return has a bishop
knight combo and white will try to
occupy the center magnus making a bit of
a face there maybe not expecting that
move black had a bunch of options black
could also pushed a couple of different
pawns
and this is the critical try white is
getting ready to build the ultimate pawn
center if white's pawn in front of his
king can step forward two squares he'll
control the whole middle of the board
uh very
kind of double-edged play so far in the
opening so one observation let's see if
i've learned anything magnus with the
white pieces he's not gonna castle queen
side in this one yes okay nice
yeah that queen side is too open right
now yeah um it takes a while though to
castle the other way he still needs to
push a pawn then move the white light
squared bishop then move the white
knight then he can castle so he's still
pretty much three or four moves away
uh christopher you have to try and
profit from that in the meantime okay
this night move
it is known uh there is a big threat
black's queen was threatening to jump
out with a nasty check but magnus uh is
ready to block that with his knight if
he needs to the white knight looks a bit
odd but it can retreat to the f2 square
where it will sit nice
and defensively g4 yeah you've seen this
before simon um
no i mean i i was happy obviously to see
black moving the f pawn because it uh
resembles my favorite opening which is
called the dutch but i haven't seen this
g4 move david is this still or if anchor
and theory i mean i i guess it is i
think it is still still theory uh magnus
carlsen actually played this with white
pieces against alexander mirozovich and
that was a win for magnus
okay i remember michael adams the
english number one being on the black
side of this position before as well
that was a few years ago
uh essentially white is just
opening things up on the king side so
maybe kaya uh he won't be casting queen
side or kingside white in this game uh
he's kind of pushed pawns on both flanks
but for now the white king's safe-ish in
the center um he's just trying to open
up the position for those white bishops
very interesting i will have a bet with
you kyle okay i will bet because you
said he's not going to castle queen side
that he casts queen side
because that's the way life works isn't
it yeah anyhow i can bet on either king
side or no just you can go if he castles
queen side i win if he doesn't you can
do whatever else you win
i take them okay what are you betting
guys good night saturday a drink i
reckon probably probably makes sense
first round so yeah
so we'll see now so i need white to
castle that king on the weaker side of
the board it doesn't look very likely
but
as we've jinxed it i i kind of feel that
he might do at some point and uh very
interesting position though right this
so far i mean this looks like both
players definitely want to take big
risks to win uh very very imbalanced and
that's what we call the commentators
curse right if we say nothing is if we
say one specific thing is not going to
happen it always happens that's that's
why i bet that's why
you know it does look like he can't cast
the queen side that's why he will you
know that's just the way the way it
works in life isn't it yeah it looks
more likely now that that might happen
than two three moves ago yeah
maybe we can jump in
i was gonna say you know there has been
a game in the database against uh sergey
volkan against max fortune as bad news
for you simon because if they follow
that game
and uh judging by that rook move yeah
the white king is destined to go
queenside no i i win
yeah so
if the white king goes queen side i win
myself a nice cheeky beer so
well yes sorry kaya but that looks crazy
and
the bad thing kaya is that magnus's last
move moving the rook means he definitely
can't castle king side it's not legal
anymore um so either the king is
destined to stay in the center
or it's going one one way what will you
guys do what looks like the best choice
for you guys
probably costly
it's changed so much uh for example here
the rook is lining up against the black
king so it would make sense for
christopher you at some point to just
move his king into the corner then white
for example could move his queen i'm not
sure the best square and uh exactly and
we know what's happening next come on
kingy get yourself over there and for
example
and i oh and i would like to clarify
like a beer in norway is like the same
as a house nearly anywhere else in the
world so
it's it's really worth winning that bet
i feel start saving yeah
no more food for me this week
this white king is very open but i guess
it does have a lot of pawns in front to
protect it it could for example slide
over and hide behind this pawn still
looks very shaky very weak over here but
uh okay christopher you he didn't go for
that king move he just pushed upon very
sensible
and is it time will magnus get you that
beer simon will he move his queen to
this square or if he moves his queen in
any direction essentially his next move
is
uh
his next move is uh definitely going to
be to castle queenside so like it yeah
i'm not so sure i think kyle might still
be okay
i suspect that the white king might find
a home on the f2 square yeah i think
it's kind of 50 50. i have to say i
think it's it's still a fair a fair bet
because there's many other moves in
there david i mean you could start by
moving your knight on the rim that
that's saying knights on the rim are dim
or there's many sayings like that you
can start moving out towards the center
looks very logical um and i think that's
probably what i would think about doing
or you could try to get your light
square bishop in the game as well but i
don't think you need to rush for that so
there's other plans here certainly i i
think i think in some ways though
christopher should be quite happy with
this position david and your vancouver
because
he wants a sharp game he wants
counter-attacking and you know with what
might be opposite side castling he's
going to get tactical opportunities um
which suits his style so um so it could
could work in his favor yeah susan style
and he's never really going to beat
magnus in a kind of slow strategic
battle or in kind of a maneuvering type
of end game so i mean this is pretty
much
all you can hope for especially with the
black pieces if you want to win
of course a draw is a decent result
against magnus and you can do that in a
variety of ways if you play really
really well but here all three results
are possible and for the standings i
mean a win here would be huge for
christopher okay the knight does
centralize as you pointed out simon very
logical move it's good for you kaia the
longer he delays castling the less
likely it will become yeah we haven't
kind of clarified the rules when it
comes to this bet what happens if the
king does not move then i win then i
lose yeah basically it's he has to
castle throughout the game if he doesn't
cast the queen side i i will happily buy
kaya
and you drink wine as well yeah really
expensive wine probably as well yeah
okay
come on beer save me so
i'm not betting against me because i
don't drink wine or beer oh that'd be a
good bet though yeah
a nice fizzy water for you
i would have to go off thank you it's a
spiritual whiskey yeah oh wow okay
the hard stuff
yeah whiskey in norway i can only
imagine how much that costs there so
don't bet with me right
um but yeah i mean it's a weird position
how does black get counter play here i
mean black's got to develop those queen
side pieces i guess um i mean if i was
black here i'd be looking at maybe
throwing the knight to the edge just
trying to get some some ideas going from
from the black side which knight are you
thinking simon uh one of these pieces
yeah i'm thinking one of the under
undeveloped pieces i i can maybe target
those double pawns this is a very normal
plan in this opening than nimzo indian
uh when you've got we call them double
pawns pawns in front of each other
they're generally quite weak because
they're a bit hard to defend they're a
bit clumsy so a very normal idea is to
attack those pawns so this would be you
know uh logical move the knight to try
and uh come in and maybe you can back it
up with a bishop attacking that pawn and
even a queen at some stage if things go
ideally so
that looks like one plan at least that
black could try here
um very sensible he plays that move he
has i think he's got to try to get
counter play i i don't know if magnus
has got anything immediate i i feel like
maybe not at the moment he's just got to
get some more pieces in the game
um
very interesting position i mean do you
like magnus's position it looks
strange to me with the poems all over
the place
it's very weird i wouldn't like it just
because my style i want a bit more
control a bit more harmony and
fewer kind of long-term deficiencies
like these pawns but
maybe simon you will like the kind of
attacking potential that white has on
this open line the black king is also
quite uh
well it's a significant target
um you have the potential of more
central pawns it's not possible right
now but if white can ever kind of
support this pawn push then white will
have three nice pawns in the center of
the board
so there are pluses and minuses for both
sides black is kind of deprived of any
uh dark square control because he's
parted with his dark square bishop
earlier in the game
and black's pieces still need a while to
come out into the game it's maybe a bit
easier for white's pieces
to do that so yeah i mean it's just a
fascinating position it's so imbalanced
and
it shows that magnus is really playing
for the win but uh christopher
fighting fire with fire and uh right now
i'm expecting either this bishop to come
out
not sure really what it's doing now but
it looks like a decent square or
what else the white queen might have to
move it might be time to get ready for
simon to win that bet
um the queen might move and
the king might run away to safety yeah
maybe the white knight
could it come into the center i mean
it's one of those weird positions that
yuvanka what are so many
peculiar ideas i know i mean it's very
very strange i almost feel like black
probably has to wait and see what white
does before actually taking any
decisions as to where to develop the
minor pieces
um you know because then at least the
plans are simpler because as it stands
there seems to be a rather odd position
i've never seen anything like this it's
a very weird position and i really do
think that would favor christopher you
know because uh you know if we have a
standard kind of position magnus
experience will come through and the
more weird the position i think the more
you know more unbalanced still so young
there's so many positions he hasn't seen
yet
imagine when he's seen them all yeah
[Laughter]
yeah the king deciding to park itself on
this square yeah it looks safer here it
does look safer but if you look at
black's rook the black crook next to his
king the black works on the same file as
this white king
so long term there might be some tricks
and look at the bar it's gone in
christopher's favor after that really
rubbish move
magnus you deserve to lose now for not
winning my bets
um so
yeah i mean but we did mention that yeah
it's quite a sensible square it's
logical and if worse comes to the worst
the white king only needs two more moves
to kind of shuffle to the right and then
shuffle into the bottom right corner and
in the corner of the board it will be
completely safe
so magnus i think he's just keeping his
options open he didn't feel that the
queen side was safe long term you have
the same instincts as kai there but uh
yeah right now it's still very tense
maybe that's the norwegian school of
chess just never castle queensland
yeah and uh it's up to christopher's
ivanka mentioned to try and activate
those black pieces it's not entirely
easy black's light squared bishop's
still
struggling to get anywhere active
yeah and i quite like that me because
white's also pairing maybe a little pawn
push
um with the king is guarding a dark
square diagonally uh you know that the
queen may have the black queen may have
jumped into so you can move your pawn up
one square and the light squared bishop
you know at the start of the game you
just want to play kind of simple moves
don't you want to develop your knights
and bishops at the start of the game and
the only piece that magnus hasn't
developed is his light squared bishop
and now he's trying to possibly prepare
that one to come into the center which
kind of looks like the ideal square
because it's pointing towards black's
king so that that maybe is what uh the
real reason behind this uh king move is
so yeah he's like what does black do now
i mean you this this looks really
logical doesn't it david the knight
jumping over there um and now you'll
move simon pushing the pawn forward you
defend it uh with the bishop
and as you mentioned this pawn push was
never ever possible until your king
supported it
yeah this is actually the dream square
you're talking to your pieces there
aren't you yeah yeah and they're all
kind of working well and you've got the
open i mean white's got this lovely we
call it open file you know your your
pieces that work in a straight line
brooks and queens they love it when
there's no pawns in the way of them
because they can zoom up the board do
zoomies
all the way towards the opponent's king
so that is a it's a nice little zoomy
towards the black king there that rook
wants um there's some tactics maybe
against this pawn that will be pinned
certainly but uh yeah right now
christopher's struggling to come up with
a move i mean this one looks natural
it's just how you back it up
and you can't develop your bishop right
now because it will simply be captured
or it can be forked immediately
for example in this way attacking two
pieces at once
you can develop to it the piece to this
square and the bishop can go to d7 but
it's not really doing much there to be
honest and you leave yourself vulnerable
to
captures like bishop takes knight this
is true actually might be winning as you
imagine ivanka hitting this rook also
hitting this pawn and there'll be some
forks instead christopher brings his
knight back to the edge of the board it
was here
about five six moves ago and the black
knight and wow what a move from magnus
uh he meets this offer of a nitrate by
pushing his double pawn forward
what could the idea be there well he's
really opening the light squares
towards black's king isn't he here so
the problem with uh one of christopher's
earlier moves moving that pawn in front
of the rook is you do weaken the black
king
and i think magnus's ideas is to try and
punish that with that diagonal david
that you pointed out maybe somehow but
it's risky right i mean uh you're you're
potentially losing a pawn here you're
sacrificing pawns so and he played that
immediately without any thought as well
so
very interesting position glad i'm glad
we picked this game yeah this is a good
game to pick so shaping up nicely uh
what happens now guys though if the pawn
is just captured
what could this band be i have nothing i
just like uh
yeah this is a check the king has to run
into the corner and now
and now what is uh
[Laughter]
no more checks okay well he wants to i
think he wants to do that check with a
bishop ivanka which makes it's a bit
more harmonious isn't it like because
then the queen might want to come the
other way
because if the queen can come over to
the king side i like this idea i think
this is the idea so the bishop wants to
check for example yeah and then the
queen because you need the queen to kill
your opponent's king normally and now
you can start moving that one over
towards the king's side and
that starting to look really dangerous
that position i think for black this
must be the idea i guess you're right
and magnus has given up a pawn but maybe
pawns aren't too important right now um
it's all about the two bishops for
example if there is a night trade ever
these two bishops are going to be
fantastic pieces and uh christopher you
react by preempting any checks if we go
back to the current position he just
puts his king in the corner
voluntarily do you want to have another
bet kyle
defense um i'm gonna bet that magnus
doesn't win this game that's a really
risky bet but i'm already one bet down
i've got a i've got to up the antes now
so i'm gonna and that is a good bet you
could be two glasses of wine up on the
saturday
what is this oh well i just i just
thought
you could better coke or it doesn't have
to be wine it could be uh
you're betting that it's a draw or a win
for christopher yes oh wait so that
would be so kyle would have two results
you would have one no
other way around i'm sorry yeah so i
would bet that either black is gonna
draw this game or or win this game which
is a really i'm not sure i'd like that
bet i just thought i just kind of like
the way the position is going
you know what i'll set a good example uh
to be happy with my one win and just
step away from more betting very wise i
feel yeah yeah i mean it's not really a
bit it's a sportsman uh
we don't agree with betting it's a
sportsman
thing
probably
you know you are one of the best chess
players in the world you know you love
competition
you just can't i don't know there's
there's an online word in the chest uh
chess world
to do with what you just did it's called
win quit
a good thing
but it's a smart thing it is definitely
you know that's why i never became a
good athlete in any way i'm you know not
competitive enough does that mean you
don't think magnus is also going to win
this position you don't have faith and i
have faith in the young one christopher
you i like you know i like the records
what if he sets the record kaia the last
time you supported magnus you bet for
magnus i ended up in a teletubby costume
you could have done all sorts of
assignments there's no way exactly no
telly tubby caution for me i'll just
clarify that
you have to find a very big costume
that wind-quitting thing is the most
frustrating thing in the world when you
play an opponent online
one game for example they have white
they
they win on time in a lost position and
then they refuse to give you a rematch
that's the oh it makes my blood boil
that's what you've just done to simon
i'm desperately trying to win back my
point yeah this is not gonna work i'm
gonna regret it now if magnus wins yeah
yeah no
but uh i mean the only reason i'm saying
that is i i quite like what black's
doing i mean i i magnus is taking risks
and and i thought if the game had gone
another way with magnus trying to you
know take no risks not sacrificing
anything playing it very slowly very
positionally um he'll just outplay
christopher and i totally understand
what magnus is playing he's great at
every form of chess and i still think
he's probably favorite to win he is the
world champion but i kind of you know i
think it's getting very exciting now and
you know the young christopher does
thrive in interesting positions so um so
that's why i thought it was an
interesting you know thing to go on and
i fought against this move as well now
black should move his knight to the edge
of the board this is this is why this is
another reason why i thought old black
might be doing
okay
yeah because you know if that bishop
that's just moved can stay on that
diagonal then i i i really like white's
position you know because it just looks
so strong but black can now start
playing with his pieces
and uh start you know start start
harassing them you know and i think it's
just an unbalanced position but it's uh
you know it looks like uh
it looks fun it does it does look like a
fun position but i kind of have a
question for you because the position to
me looks totally wild should black be
kind of like playing
like simon is like like in just
enhancing the tension or should he
perhaps kind of go
swap everything off
if you could swap everything off that'd
be amazing
there's a lot of things to swap well i
did think that it was possible you could
first of all swap off the knights i know
i know i know it lengthens the rook i'm
aware of that but then you could also
because the bishop is unprotected
actually
no ah you can maybe maybe attack the
attack than the bishop first it's kind
of
yeah i mean you could move the bishop in
front of the queen couldn't you
potentially because bishop takes bishop
unfortunately
banner in the works okay first so yeah
forking yeah yeah one peaceful drop
there um so potentially for example you
could move your knight to the edge of
the board yeah i think white will drop
his bishop back this way maybe but if it
drops this way you could try and trade
it off
or you could potentially block it up at
some point push this pawn not in this
exact position but uh
yeah i guess the risk involved here is
that white's going to start ganging up
on this pawn already and the black king
is going to be very vulnerable
i think this is making christopher
hesitate from putting his knight on the
edge of the board okay he plays a very
risky move instead he pushes a pawn and
that weakens thinking even further that
looks crazy risky to me because look at
that square next to the pawn david as
well right square yeah if a knight ever
lands here safely it's just gonna be
game over but christopher and all of the
young generation nowadays they're very
concrete they don't see ghosts then
fearless
yes it might weaken a square but if it
works move by move then
why not and he's asked the big question
of this bishop if this bishop retreats
then actually this will favor black
hugely after a night trade suddenly
white has these two weak pawns and her
white's king is open
so i don't think we'll see a bishop
retreat from magnus if knight takes
knight
i guess the queen will come out and
recapture
um i don't think you can take the bishop
here because white's rook will recapture
and
uh oh this king is too open
so we would see uh for example the black
queen come out the white bishop drop
back and what has christopher gained
here
yes the queen is active but it's not
really going anywhere anytime soon
a bit of an odd choice but the computer
quite likes it still thinking it's
roughly balanced
yeah do you know do you know who magnus
is playing like in this game
well at least uh who i think magnus's
play reminds me of a bit of that
that's a hint you're gonna say i think
you're gonna say alpha zero i was gonna
i was gonna i was gonna say like even
out of stock fish yeah just don't remind
me of alpha zero just giving up pawns
alpha zero is obsessed with the two
bishops as well yeah um i've seen alpha
zero games where white gives up four
pawns just for the bishop pair and some
kind of long-term attack which from
human eyes looked like
actually it's not that dangerous but
long-term
white gets the attack and it's all about
whether this unrivaled dark square
bishop
this one can later
not right now because it gets captured
by the black knight but whether it can
later target the black king
alpha zero also loves its pawn centers
so even what magnus did earlier giving
up a pawn on this square
it just really brings back shades and we
know that magnus was inspired in early
2019
uh the best form of his life was when he
was inspired by alpha zero interesting
yeah
and this uh this whole idea of just
dominating the dark squares is very very
powerful
i mean i wonder if you can throw the
queen over now
i mean uh in the current position i want
to get more pieces towards black's king
but
i wonder about it but i'm kind of like
not wondering too much maybe i mean it's
a kind of natural move because
you know black's king is very weak you
know there's holes around it there's
diagonals towards it there's a lot of
white pieces but i'm not going to cause
any damage without the queen joining in
uh i was thinking even maybe takes part
but
i mean
i don't really believe it but you can
see here i have a checkmate threat um so
at least it gives black something to
think about uh this kind of idea and i
want to i really want to get the queen
into the game
uh in this position so that i mean
that's the kind of thing i'm sure magnus
has to calculate right because if it
works it could be extremely strong
and of course he can't see the
evaluation bar you know for us we can
see it doesn't win but for magnus he you
know maybe he's thinking there's a big
move here yeah and i guess in this
position black could defend by bringing
the rook up uh and not blocking any
checks but it's still hanging by a
thread for black uh black would have an
extra night here but still i mean
ongoing attack
against uh this pawn
that's uh yeah i mean these there's two
options right as you say simon in the
current position either you just
swap the knights off you take the
knights off the board and then you drop
back with your bishop play positionally
long term
or you just do something crazy uh it
could be a sacrifice on this square it
could be a sacrifice here this crossed
my mind as well bishop takes pawn and
then jumping in with the knight with a
check we talked about this square
uh the king would move i guess and
knight takes with a check
okay he just goes for the slower
approach maybe in this position of rook
versus two knights he couldn't find a
knockout blow
and uh let's go back to the game
it's all about the power of these
bishops
yeah and your instincts were correct
david and gosh it's an exciting game and
it's also going to be such an exciting
day
and
well
well we love it when everyone at home
kind of interacts with us and sends us
their tweets
and mohamed farah has uh caught on the
fact that we seem to have some
catchphrases
david's favorite is me and my arrows
that's true apparently i say fizzle out
to a draw quite about that before yeah
yeah and simon's peculiar
very british
julia game
[Laughter]
peculiar commentators
exactly it's easy to be on television
is yeah and uh yeah so thank you
mohammed for that great tweet and if you
too wanna
just send us your pictures your photos
tweets like mohammed's then please do so
using the hashtag chess champs and we
will feature them on the show
look at what's happening meanwhile i
mean wow this is don't move pawns in
front you're king oh hang on
do move paws around your king what a
peculiar idea
what a peculiar game in general i mean
black has broken the rule several times
moving knights to the edge of the board
magnus has broken the rules by not
castling sacrificing pawns and now
christopher you opening up his own king
by pushing pawns himself and he's forced
white star squad bishop far away and now
he's going for the white king both kings
are targets here
the black king for now is safe-ish but
there are threats against magnus's king
black's queen wants to come down and
take the white h pawn now with a nasty
check
there's another check available the
black queen can go for white central
pawn the e pawn huge pressure on that
right now
i like what he's doing just again just
all out all at magnus
this is how to kind of beat the top
players in the world just
show them no respect it might backfire
some of the time but if it works wow
this game might go down in history so
magnus is the dark squared bishop now is
it a
worse piece than it was
um it's still a good piece but white
star square bishop can't get at the
black king yet if the white square
bishop drops back and checks that black
king in the corner then the black knight
will take off that bishop the black
knight covers some very important
squares so um there's also a chance
white starts going bishop it's loose and
loose pieces we know they drop off
so there's going to be some tactics
against that piece if magnus isn't
careful
suddenly i love black's position i mean
it's still objectively in the balances
we see with the computer but
anything could happen yeah i'm just
gutted that bet it wasn't taken because
i'm actually i'm actually it it's just
you're going to say frank but it looks
to me like any result now i mean it's
such a mess and uh what brave play from
the young christopher so he's you know
admirable play so far yeah i was just
going to say it looks like magnus is
going to have to give up material here
and there you see it the queen takes the
pawn with check the rook will step up
and block that check
and uh the checks will carry on as the
queen moves along and checks king to the
on the diagonal
such such a wild position though because
even though white's king is pretty
exposed it doesn't feel like black's
king is all that safe either you know
one wrong move and that's it the game is
over for either side actually
i'm wondering if black was a little bit
greedy there to be honest because now
um white's king seems very safe to me
and i agree with you anchor i think it's
black's king that could come under some
fire those bishops the rook and
a fianchettoed rook which white has that
rook in front of the king is a
tremendous
piece defending you can't check mate
really when your opponent's got
fianchettoed rook
so i'm kind of i'm kind of bit fearful
actually for black's position without
doing any calculation now so yeah but i
think maybe the bishop will have to
start coming out and start attacking the
white rook
because like you said it was such a good
defender yeah and uh white's king now
wants to hide in the corner on h1
uh the white rook will still protect it
there but
as you guys say it's the price of every
move is so high right now the stakes are
just rising move by move
um christopher slightly lower on the
clock that could be a factor but as
ivanka said he plays very well good
instincts uh when low on time
if the black rooks could somehow line up
with the white king maybe some chances
but
yeah if black's initiative if the
little momentum dries up then uh it's
all gonna be about those white bishops
okay christopher takes the pawn
the white king does hide so right now
the material count is black has an extra
pawn but the material is secondary here
it's just about whether white bishops
can get to that black king
do you think christopher will try to
put his rook on the g line and just
go for broke you know sacrifice material
just to get at the white king yeah i
think he's threatening to win a pizza as
well isn't he just by moving the bishop
all the way back i mean
look at those pieces on the
file right on the edge of the board
they're all lined up there but that
white rook is very powerful
lined up against two of black's most
powerful pieces the queen and the king
eventually
uh so it christopher has to be very
careful here
really careful in this position ivanka's
move here rook to g8 this would involve
a sacrifice as you mentioned bishop can
take this rook uh but now there's a big
threat of the bishop jumping out the way
with a check
how do we defend against that i mean i
only see a couple of ways we have to
guard this square either we use the
white rook to protect the square from
the side or we use the white queen i'm
not sure which square is best i love the
idea though
i love that i mean i love this side and
if you can swing the uh if you can swing
the knight around to g3
you only you only need about three moves
surely there's enough time to do that
but uh
i mean that would be fantastic so i
really
can is he going to do it next move i
mean
see the evaluation bar swing across
maybe this was a bit of a slip up by
chris for you it makes sense he's
attacking this bishop yep the bishop
only really has one safe square uh it
again doesn't want to go into the center
yet to check because it can just be
captured by the black knight so magnus
drops it back
to d6 instead hitting this rook
and the rook moves okay hitting the
bishop now
so how does he keep this bishop alive
so he's doing ivanka's plan but he's
trying to keep both rooks on the board
and it but it does seem like the
diagonals towards black's king are going
to be very exposed as well
for example if you take this pawn just
to guard your bishop uh yeah as you say
simon this diagonal
if you just land one check later for
white it's going to be game over at the
moment you can't because the black
knight covers this square and uh this
square
me and my arrows the knight covers these
two squares but uh yeah i guess this is
the plan right christopher wants to
switch his rook
how do we defend against that
wild stuff completely wild crazy and the
evaluation bar might favor white but i
mean all three results still on the
cards for sure this is the current
position
okay he needed to defend this bishop
magnus so he plays the most natural move
he takes a pawn
and
whose attack is going to be quicker
and surely now the rook has to move over
i mean christopher's then got three
pieces against white's king that one
rook in front of white's king is saving
it and the rook is a great defender
but you know it's a little bit scary and
uh that's right yeah massive threat
there we should win the game if you can
get that check in so
on the defensive magnus maybe he's it's
time to use the sleeping rook on the a1
square move move it up to the second row
i love these kind of moves just to guard
this square i mean i'm scared what
happens if black brings his remaining
rook into the game now oh sorry now slip
uh to this square sorry the e8 square
threatening to come down with a deadly
check
looks nasty
suddenly black's attack looks more
dangerous than whites what if what if
you made the also the bishop all the way
back as well as your vancouver's move
sorry for
looking at you know jumping ahead there
but potentially this move defends and
attacks yeah because you're defending
that check that black was planning but
the special is pinned as well that could
be yeah it looks scary to allow some
check on this square but at the moment
white has everything covered maybe black
just has to defend his bishop
i can't see anything else in that
position
uh but this one i mean it looks really
awkward this tension between the white
rook the black bishop the black queen
but uh
how do you overwhelm how do you win a
piece it's all about whether black can
get his rook into attack and whether
white can get his rook into the defense
these are the two sleeping pieces
so tense and okay magnus moves his queen
instead that's the one option we didn't
consider the idea is that the bishop
check now is met by a short-term queen
sacrifice you take the bishop
uh the white queen drops but then the
black queen drops afterwards and white
wins a piece in that process
so you are covering all the checks
it makes sense now there's threats of
this bishop check for white
the queen drops in how scary is this so
many pieces near this white king but no
threat yet that i can see
is it time for white to maybe bring this
piece into the game
what a game what a game and remember
christopher you 15 points he is in ninth
place currently one spot away from top
eight to qualify for the knockout stage
the youngest player in the tournament
playing a fearless game here against
world number one magnus carlson
[Music]
it looks really scary for white but if
you're objective there is no threat yeah
so this means that you have some extra
time and you kind of mentioned bringing
in the rook i was just also thinking uh
yeah
that's much more magnus's style right
i mean the white light squared bishop
could have moved as well to attack a few
things but
this makes sense and i don't really see
how that black rook at the top of the
board is getting in the game that's the
problem maybe for christopher you he
doesn't have any safe squares or any
active safe squares to go to
i can't see any plan for black
that's actually maybe the problem right
i mean black's got the three pieces
around white's king but they're not
really threatening anything and the rule
is when you're attacking which black's
trying to do you need to bring in your
reinforcements so you start to look at
the knight and the other rook and as you
said david the other rook has no squares
it can come into and the knight also has
no roots it can move to so
logically what what actually can black
do in this position what piece what plan
can black play i can't i can't see a
move here for black um you know which
is worrying obviously if you can't see
it moving
white can just improve as he's done with
the last move
um anyone see an idea for black i'm
really struggling actually here to find
a plan he has to move soon he's only got
one minute and i'm the same as you simon
i can barely see a productive move for
black okay he moves his rook
um so
i'm not exactly sure what the idea
behind that one is maybe it'll shuffle
across to the h file add more pressure
there but
uh i guess that's also why the
evaluation bar is on white side right
now because black is struggling for
plans
magnus needs a plan of his own however
and uh which piece can be improved now
you don't want to touch the white rook
in front of the king you don't want to
touch the white queen
or really the other white rook so it
might be the bishops by process of
elimination could you also try to swap
off queens you know we can kind of say
that a lot
oh okay
he sees the future
is that favor white
well we kind of have this rule that when
you're on the defensive and your king is
feeling slightly unsafe i mean slightly
in the british way you know it's very
unsafe try and swap of queens the
queen's is a dangerous attacker yeah and
also i go on about this a lot but the
two bishops when you have the bishop
pair the fewer pieces remain the more
powerful those bishops become
if the queens disappear white's bishops
will be free to just wreak havoc
yeah looks like a very strong safe move
there by magnus the queens do disappear
and now we enter a completely different
phase of the game there won't be
checkmates yet at least not against the
white king
the black king in the corner feels
vulnerable to the bishops
and christopher you he has ticked under
one minute on the clock now ticking down
to 30 seconds but he looks so calm this
15 year old
impressive stuff
yeah very impressive i mean he's played
a great game so far right yes the
evaluation bar might think white is
doing well but he's been so creative
christopher
still fighting very well and this game's
far from over
okay white's rook comes back to that
great defensive square and black pushes
a pawn
harry the edge porn yeah
i mean he's done well but
it does seem like those bishops as you
as you mentioned look at white you know
oh no yeah i mean it's it's an open
board
this um when i mean open board there's
so many lines which is no pawns are
blocking and bishops just work so well
and uh
look at the rook the rook is also now
coming in it it's starting to really
look a bit dicey for black i think now
yeah let's i mean let's examine the
problems there are a few problems here
firstly it's level material but this
pawn can be taken any time this pawn is
actually very very weak and as simon
mentions the rook is coming in with a
nasty check supported by this bishop
how do you stop that the only move to
stop that is to move your bishop away
again but white's rook will have several
ways in including by just going after
this pawn
okay christopher you tries to break his
own rook out of its current prison it's
completely dominated by white's bishops
but
okay where is the knockout
it feels like this rook is almost
trapped but uh you can flick in this
bishop move you can flick in a check
with the white rook
too many options for magnus almost i
mean there's two bishops and a rook
attacking the black king now and that is
a lot of pieces
i mean uh you know i love the idea
i mean the rook check looks the most
obvious and he's played it yeah and then
you know you can also play the bishop in
to attack
or this one yeah i mean the bishop to
one square yeah
to undermine this bishop which is
actually pinned on the eighth rank this
looked very strong magnus went for a
different move
he dropped his rook back so i guess he
wants to create some mating attack with
his bishops now
um
okay he wanted to drop back with a check
so this was blocked by christopher you
very good move
or at least very logical move um
just blocking any tracks okay he's got
his king slightly safer than it was
stop fighting so well christopher that
last move seems key doesn't it you know
bringing that bishop to to stop a lot of
checks and magnus now switching plans a
little bit so uh
tying down black's rook can't move
because you win the night and uh black's
got to find a move here that's a really
clever move that's such a clever endless
isn't it just when you think maybe you
have a chance magnus goes no
there you go you have to put your knight
on the edge of the board i'm not a
bishop and now he's going the other way
that's
really clever play ruthless
yeah it's just about these bishops they
are dominating everything right now
looks like magnus
big favorite
and
a big result in the game between levon
and prague a win and three points for
levon that is super good news for the
american because he needs to stack up
points today to qualify for the knockout
stage niman in huge trouble in his game
if he loses this chances are
even bigger he will be in that eighth
place who currently
faces magnus carlsen in the
quarterfinals wow
yeah wow it's going to be a very
dramatic last couple of rounds of the
prelims
and uh meanwhile magnus has grabbed a
pawn uh with his last move it's still
level material black took a pawn as well
but the black knight is running out of
squares ah it's not just the knight
that's a problem it's the black king i
mean that is in a checkmating net
what a move though from christopher u
using all tactics to to try and survive
this one
uh the rook has lined up against the
king but i guess you know the king can
simply move
worst case scenario
and it looks like hans is literally
doing everything to come eighth
so
that's a joke
just clarify
um meanwhile the white king did get out
of the way of any just potential
discover checks on that g-file the white
king just sidestepped and
the black knight had to run this
knight's really struggled it's gone to
the edge of the board it got kicked back
now it's gone to the top of the board
and it's running out of squares still
magnus
even if the rooks come off to be honest
white's rook is better than the black
fruit right now but even if the rooks
come off it looks very good for white
all of black's pawns are weak
and it is a loss for hans niemann in his
game against ivan zarich that means ivan
sarge
he climbs on the table still outside top
eight and niman's still inside
but that eighth place is getting closer
for him and if magnus wins this game
it is looking more likely that magnus
will win the preliminaries it's uh one
point for arjun air guys in second point
with a draw in this round against
vojtech
yeah very tense yeah it's going to be a
brilliant finish today um you know we've
got going to have two games left after
this i mean who knows who's going to
qualify and play who tomorrow it's going
to be so exciting i know yeah yeah
there's literally been times as well on
the tour that uh it's come down to the
last few moves
in order to see who gets through often
one player is finished waiting hoping
that another game goes their way and
hoping that a certain result appears
meanwhile magnus uh he's safe he's
through to the knockouts but he dropped
his bishop back attacking black's rook
and the rook shuffled
into the corner
whoa that's not the square you want to
use
he's i mean he's trying everything to
defend this but
this is like you know the bishops are
just i mean it all started with this
beautiful pawn sacrifice that magnus
played he played this as you said alpha
zero kind of move to get the bishops uh
working in such a beautiful way and it's
it's been a great game so far this one
really really good yeah just gotta now
coordinate a little bit better with the
rook
uh how did you move it do you try to
attack the bishop to try to get it to
check the king one file forwards
which you can't do at the moment as many
sort of
tempting options are yeah i know very a
lot of tempting moves like i was
thinking you could just go pawn hunting
but he's gone for attacking the bishop
still feels like black's king is
walking such a tight rope i feel like
he's going to get checkmated any time
now you know with those two bishops like
sniffing around
yeah yeah
it's looking very dodgy oh
it's never nice moving your piece back
to
if he just moves his knight back he's
got you know them all in the starting
squares ready for the next game
get them set up
so i think we might see
checkmate and this game it feels like
the black king has got almost zero
escape squares it's only got the one
next to it right now and magnus he can
give a check with his light squad bishop
he can give a check with his rook
looks so promising we saw magnus as well
lean in after that last move was played
he smells the checkmate he senses it
and
at the very least he will be able to win
a couple of pawns most likely but uh
yeah where is the killer blow and also
what's black's next move this is always
worth thinking about when you're playing
chess don't just think of your own ideas
because if you can't see a win think
what's my opponent going to play next
and try to find a move for your opponent
and again if you get into the habit of
doing that this is why magnus might have
played a quiet move he's doing that i
think he's thinking what can my opponent
move next
and
most of the moves that black can play
lose something actually here um so this
is this is just a great way to think
when you're playing so he's moved the
king but now he's lying it up to a
bishop check at some point
oh okay and he's closing the net around
the king here with that pawn
the deadly threat now is for white's
rook to step one square further forward
onto the seventh rank one second black
king did he make a move yeah he did yeah
he made it
oh but that's it that's it i mean look
at that rook it's going to give a check
king is forced to step backwards up game
over yeah
ah it is over but what a fight from
christopher you against the world
champion magnus crossing but it is 3